use the world times like that to find
the stereotype in the following cities
with 12 noon in Greenwich okay so I'm
just beginning to question one on a per
time and this is the way I would suggest
that you write it
Perth is I can actually go back we've
got the trailer the same time let's see
if we manage okay
how about with her what I could do it in
Pompeii right so per time is UTC plus 8
that's the way that you would like okay
so if it's really Greenwich then I'll
have to add eight hours to that so it's
8 p.m. in um I would suggest that you
blog both of these things personally
identify the timezone batted in and then
secondly applied it to whatever time it
currently happens to be so for instance
if it wasn't news branch if I said ok
what if it was something like say 7:30
p.m. in Greenwich
how are you going to work this out all
you do you're still going to add the 8
hours but where's it going to land you
you've got to be a little bit careful on
this so it's going to yeah
as you add hours if only what it is is
only 400 hours to design right once you
get the midnight then you're in the next
day aren't you
so therefore itself it appear to
Greenwich it's going to be 3:30 a.m. and
please like this it's 3:00 a.m. in Perth
but it's the next day right because not
only is the time change you've gone past
midnight for the whole new day does that
make us
I totally would I totally would because
if you're point at a time and I think
the date is equally as in water okay so
you can say let's look for San Francisco
I'm only we had someone busy to the US
retail a third quality home without can
you point us to San Francisco okay sorry
it's on the bread box dog
it's like one of the wrench of what
address whatever another I let them down
down so hard what if that one is okay
all right I'd like around there yep I
don't know you're coming
oh hey guys yeah yeah okay sorry
you come look of your artisan type of
evidence so have a look so here we are
this is the same time zone we're
interested in right and if you follow it
down you can see it's going to be is
when our careful so these colors here
these cognitive match up so I I think we
should actually have a look at Nick in
your textbook they provide one as well
suppose a yes there you go so I got sure
if maybe the color vigilantes match to
some like that I mean it clearly looks
clearly looks like ants in that zone
yeah yeah so and if the text we could
say we'll go with that then we should
just sort consistent so my eight were
they
I'm sort of writing annotation
so what we would say we're going to a
crossroad is identify the time therefore
region it'd be a little more do too much
easy
if you succeed by today's so therefore
again I want to speed it please this
time take the time in whatever location
you're compared to which typically will
be credit and then we have to rewind
right so you subtract date which gives
you Cory you don't bang it out from noon
yeah so you might find enough to really
actually talk just push it the
adaptogenic I should have mentioned this
before but but here it's answers here
it's helpful to mention it now if you're
getting a little bit confused about
classes - of where you are particularly
if they give you a different time I
suggest you draw yourself one of these
okay
doesn't have the beautiful but just
chuck in whatever records side would be
provided so we provide that in Greenwich
and then use a number line one two three
four and five six seven eight
so make sure you're mentally can see
time correctly because I am is a corbett
ears are that's incorrect for this
because we just look at the eight and we
think we're comparing to do right and we
say oh it did the body and then we just
sort of on a little island with thickest
area you can see if you go one two three
four five six seven eight hours back
there is a lemonade for ten nine eight
seven six five four am right and you can
see you can replay the other direction
you can with for a value to the another
topic that's for air
no our search you talk you talk I want
to lose you here because this is the
deputy purpose you job is still still
waiting for error words and illicitly
because it committee this is where a
number one a timeline will help you if
you got 12 dude in the middle then this
is the morning now 12 noon can way we
wrote in it is it's 12 p.m.
but I've chanted not like 12 p.m. I've
sent to write 12 News because I don't
can do that in early evolution 12
midnight when in 12 inner therefore am
right so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 is 12
midnight so in 24 hour time should say
zero hundred hours which is a bit we're
doing but in normal 12-hour time you
take 12 a.m. okay so they can carry for
12 video exact you're going into the
morning yeah I said draw that little
help